effectivement nous parler au moyen-âge
au cours de la page sculptures on va y
rester en quelque sorte bonsoir agents
d'eric dans sarah vous vous êtes le
directeur du seul établissement des
compagnons du devoir dans le département
des yvelines c'est celui des pôles je
parlais tout simplement du moyen âge
parce que c'est à cette époque que sont
nées les compagnons du devoir
c'est vrai les tresses légendaire et
écrite nous remontent au moyen-age
aujourd'hui on est une association qui a
été créée en 1947 et qui a pour but de
former des jeunes dès la sortie finale
3e voire même de bach
alors justement à l'époque on
construisait des cathédrales au
moyen-âge aujourd'hui c'est plus tout à
fait le cas
quels sont les métiers qui sont qui sont
après dans vos établissements
alors on a les métiers de la maçonnerie
la couverture la charpente du bâtiment
les métiers de l'industrie
les métiers de la mode comme maroquinier
cordonnier sellier maroquinier ou les
métiers de la bouche comme boulanger
pâtissier on a en tout 28 métier et ce
sont des métiers avec beaucoup de
débouchés
tout à fait mais en branchant ce mythe
tout à fait tout à fait aux rites ou nos
jeunes qui ont qui font leur formation
chez les compagnons de voir 95 % d'entre
eux trouvent un emploi après leur
formation donc c'est quelque chose qui
est assez intéressant car c'est tous nos
jeunes sont salariés d'entreprises et
est forcément passe beaucoup de temps en
entreprise
95 % ça veut dire qu'il ya vous
connaissez pas la crise en tout
simplement non il ya très très peu de
jeunes qui en sont sortis de formation
je ne trouve pas de l'emploi comment ça
fonctionne très très concrètement au
début on est apprenti aspirants ensuite
et puis enfin le compagnon tout à fait
en fait nos jeunes tout à fait nos
jeunes rentrer chez nous par le biais de
l'apprentissage donc et de l'alternance
donc apprennent un métier en faisant un
temps court et un temps en entreprise si
ces entreprises et deux semaines de
cours et une fois que ce petit cet
apprentissage a été fait sur une période
de deux ans de ce fait le jeune devient
un aspirant aspire à devenir compagnon
tout en faisant son tour de france
voyage en france à l'étranger
donc c'est quelque chose qui est assez
intéressant dans des petites moyennes
des grosses entreprises et la fin
devient compagne en or il en réalisant
son petit travail de réception qui
prouve un petit peu ses compétences
professionnelles qu'il aura pu assimiler
surtout son tour de france des
compagnons
justement le tour de france des
compagnons en parler c'est ça la
particularité peut-être encore plus à
mettre peut-être en avant ça fonctionne
comment c'est grâce à un réseau
d'entreprises partenaires
on a trente mille entreprises
partenaires sur le territoire français
et non en a 180 maisons de compagnons en
france donc si on fait un petit mix des
deux ça peut faire un beau un beau
cheminement un voyage où le jeune chaque
année change de ville est hébergée
restaurer dans nos maisons de compagnons
dans toutes les grandes villes de france
nous sommes implantés et donc de ce fait
le jeune apprendre des expériences
diverses et variées le secret c'est ça
cette fonctionner en réseau aussi c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il
serait sorti des études 95% ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure dé jeu ne trouve
un emploi oui certainement et puis
surtout c'est à cet enrichissement cette
adaptation à chaque environnement dans
des petites entreprises
on fonctionne pas de la même façon que
dans une grosse entreprise donc toutes
ces choses là demain donne des choses
très intéressantes sur un cv pour un
jeune qui sort de la 23 24 ans et
postule directement à une place à hautes
responsabilités dans une entreprise tout
à fait moi aussi je les fais en tant qu
elle profession vous étiez un
chaudronnier chadronnier c'est bien ça
chaudronnier
donc moi même j'ai fait mon
apprentissage dans ma région natale en
alsace j'ai fait mon apprentissage j'ai
fait ce fameux tour de france des
compagnons avec un passage à l'étranger
en espagne et donc de ce fait j'ai
acquéri aussi pas mal d'expérience
professionnelle et humaine y prévaut oui
ça signifie quoi
après vaud c'est un terme un peu anciens
qui veut dire gardiens du site
finalement et en gros on pourrait dire
ça comme aujourd'hui responsable d'un
centre de formation d'un site de
formation s qui a tous nos quelques fois
parfois en ce cas parce qu'on va en
parler il ya des porte est ouverte qui
sont organisés pour que le grand public
connaisse mieux peut-être les parents
pour inscrire aussi leurs enfants est-ce
que quelquefois il ya des réticences des
choses qui sont méconnus ça fait
peut-être un petit peu peur parce qu'on
est sur quelque chose à part qui
fonctionne en réseau avec des rites de
passage les gras est extrêmement méconnu
est parfois comparé à certaines sectes
et c'est chose qui n'est pas du tout le
cas
et donc de ce fait voilà nos jeunes
suivent suivi une formation qui
extrêmement intéressante et qui
extrêmement
valorisante on est souvent mal connus ou
peu connus c'est dommage c'est pour ça
qu'on leur conseille de venir nos
journées portes ouvertes le vendredi 22
et samedi 23 mars
le mode de fonctionnement est proche de
celui des francs-maçons aussi on est
dans la norme dans l'antre aide aussi
non ça strictement enfin et quelques
chevilles avec quelques signification
quelques symboles qui signifie un petit
peu la même chose que fonction on
fonctionne beaucoup grâce à des symboles
mais finalement ça un rien à voir avec
la prendre à sonnerie on est souvent
comparé mais on n'a rien à voir ça fait
partie des questions que vous posez
peut-être le plus souvent les parents
lorsqu'ils arrivent pour se renseigner
avant d'inscrire leurs enfants sur leur
sens et pas les crises il pas les
questions après deux mois aux sirènes
frontalement mais on est où là pour
respecter c'est pas une question
primordiale mais oui c'est des questions
qui arrive assez souvent compagnons du
devoir égale légal franc maçon et enfin
on n'a strictement rien à voir comment
ça fonctionne ensuite sur le plan
financier parce qu'il faut s'inscrire
c'est une formation à suivre
est ce que ça coûte cher à l'information
en elle même elle est gratuite et dames
à nos jeunes de voyager de d'avoir une
expérience assez intéressante un passage
à l'étranger dans de devenir bilingue de
passer diplôme pouvait acheter une
licence donc ça aussi c'est quelque
chose d'assez intéressant un bac + 4 et
donc de ce fait les jeunes sont la
formation est gratuite
elle n'a aucun coup la seule chose qui
ait un coup finalement c'est
l'hébergement et la restauration
on va savoir que tout 100% nos jeunes
sont forcément salariés d'une entreprise
ont forcément un salaire et comment vous
réussissez à fonctionner sur ce mode
gratuit
les ressources que vous que vous
réussissez à dégager pour permettre de
payer les enseignants tout simplement
grâce à des partenariats grâce à une
entraide grâce à des aléas des salles et
des sources financières qu'on arrive à
mettre en place pour justement
positionner nos formateurs et
accompagner les jeunes grâce au conseil
régional par exemple grâce à la taxe
d'apprentissage
voilà ce qui nous aide a justement
subventionné
nos formateurs et à des les jeunes à se
former c'est formateur
ils viennent d'où bah 90% vient de fsh
et nationale parce qu'ils sont des
professionnels bien sûr ces professeurs
en partenariat par le cnam auxquels ces
prophètes des professeurs des formateurs
de maths français enlevés qui ont un
niveau forcément en adéquation avec les
besoins des jeunes
portes ouvertes à travers la france pour
la cinquantaine d'établissements des
compagnons du devoir notamment une porte
ouverte à l'époque dans votre
établissement
à partir de quel âge on peut rentrer
dans vos étapes dès la sortie de
troisième il faut avoir faut avoir le
diplôme ou pas du tout peu importe il
faut être motivé
c'est la grande grande chose qu'il faut
avoir cette motivé parce que vous avez
beaucoup de demandes on a énormément de
demandes via une sélection sur dossier à
une sélection sur dossier en effet ya un
petit test de positionnement à faire
mais on recrute énormément de jeunes
sortis de troisième on recrute de plus
en plus et la sortie de back parce que
beaucoup de jeunes vont jusqu'au bac et
après ne s'oriente pas vers 11 et une
donc nous rejoindre pour faire un métier
un petit peu plus concret et donc de se
faire de plus en plus et on a aussi des
jeunes qui se forment à d'autres cf et
qui revient spécialement pour le tour de
france des compagnons mais jusqu'à quel
âge on peut postuler jusqu'à 20 21 22
ans n'y a pas de formation fait pour les
adultes 1 si on fait aussi la formation
a dit m c'est une petite majorité ont
fait aussi en fait aussi une formation
pour les adultes une formation continue
la reconversion professionnelle etc et
porte est ouverte du 22 au 24 mars trois
précisément 23 mars pour votre
établissement pourrait pour répondre
comment vont se dérouler ces journées
porte est ouverte
c'est une journée continue hockey le nos
jeunes qui sont qui vivent sur le site
vont faire des ateliers vivants afin de
découvrir et de démontrer leur métier de
maître aussi des tiges les jeunes vont
pour apposer un mur en parpaings couper
un petit bout de bois etc
voilà c'est pour donner un petit peu
goût aux familles et puis surtout pour
découvrir certains métiers qui sont
parfois méconnus je prends l'exemple ya
beaucoup de personnes qui savent pas ce
que c'est le métier de chaudronnier donc
c'est important de l'expliquer aussi
lors de nos journées portes ouvertes
on parle de compagnons g de voir les
filles aussi sans les bienvenus
bien sûr les solutions bienvenu on a on
a énormément de jeunes filles de plus en
plus sur des métiers joue cité de la
mode et de la bouche des maroquiniers
des cordonniers satyanand et moi les
jeunes
si on a de plus en plus et ils sont la
bienvenue merci d'amérique pour ses
portes ouvertes les compagnons du devoir
les renseignements pratiques qui se sont
affichés merci à vous c'est la fin de
cette édition du 7 8
je vous retrouve demain jeudi 18 heures
d'ici là vous pouvez revoir nos
reportages nos interviews sur le site
internet de la chaîne consultation libre
vous en avez l'habitude et n'oubliez pas
également de nous suivre sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook et twitter excellente
soirée
new delhi